appel de nicolas sarkozy l'ancien chef
par messages interposés que que ça
républicains semblent de plus en plus
objectif c'est en quelque sorte de
semaine il ya eu une réunion des députés
manière générale ils sont très bien
électeurs des sympathisants et des élus
député également
valérie pécresse n'a même pas dépassé
à chaque fois d'autant qu'en 2017 il ya
a été atteint j'ai l'impression au cours
en mauvais état à l'époque emmanuel là
assez amical assez constructive assez
celui qui est le plus courtisé n'a pas
guillaume larrivé genre d'honneur de
prochaines semaines tout un fait il y
même quelque chose qui est assez
implantés ils sont connus de leurs
de rester unis et surtout d'aller
premiers constructif justement auprès
mal de personnes je pense notamment à
sans faire élire forcément beaucoup de
fragilisé par la stratégie du président
disant en fait il est en train de me
principal c'est de rester le premier
marquant c'est localement le lait leers
certes c'est plus que valérie pécresse
déstabiliser les républicains et d'aller
et il a été il a été recruté ensuite par
pour récupérer la plus grande partie de
aient l'air à l'assemblée nationale il
aura des tractations elles continuent
franchi le pas
n'a même pas fait 5 % la droite est déjà
daniel fasquelle on en parlait des gens
depuis le
rachida dati nadine morano qui reste de
parler aujourd'hui et des républicains
dire qu'il ne va pas nous trahir mais on
qu'on avait tout intérêt à nommer un
administrés et malgré le score assez
de cette de cette élection déjà
devient un petit peu plus un petit peu
eu des ralliements il ya eu des
mais sa force d'attractivité abc vite à
de sa famille politique aujourd'hui on
chercher des victoires localement c'est
de la république c'est à dire en fait
l'assemblée nationale est la même et il
lit un petit peu le contraire donc ça a
premier ministre de droite aujourd'hui
le pas de nicolas sarkozy vers emmanuel
mais hier lors du comité stratégique il
tours qui a appelé sa famille politique
ya eu un comité stratégique de tous les
sérieuse chacun expose son point de vue
d'élus locaux a débauché de plus en plus
après les investitures seront seront
de ce qui se passe au sein du parti des
chercher des personnalités de la droite
encore très présents localement et
plutôt que d'essayer de gagner des
très fidèle
cette somme et on voit ces derniers
qui ont un certain poids mais pas non
le président de la république auprès de
à dire que les députés sortants de
plus violents mais pour l'instant dans
trahisons et c'est donc là dans
été un petit peu un petit peu chaud il
nationalement on a l'impression que il
vis-à-vis de beaucoup de militants nous
avait même été nommé questeur ce qui
c'est un peu moins le cas
pour faire exploser la droite
du coup on ne sent plus proche du
faible de valérie pécresse très faible
nationale donc ce qui va essayer d'être
a collaboré avec emmanuel macron qui est
macron il ya beaucoup d'élus qui
républicains je suis avec wally bordage
plus d'aider des cadors de chez
lui pour un petit peu faire faire
les réunions l'ambiance est relativement
élections c'est on va prouver retire
et puis il n'a pas repris la parole
chacun écoute l'autre
ténors de la droite qui a eu lieu hier
avait créé un petit scandale puisque
vide des républicains certains qui
ya eu des messages envoyés il ya eu des
jours l art posté un message sur twitter
effectivement est ce que on parle
maquereau nice finalement que des
marque le pas mais il ça reste une force
d'élus locaux là par exemple c'est le
l'état-major des républicains tout le
s'est abstenu de voter pour le ni ni
très rapidement les premiers le premier
entre guillemets des gens qui ont déjà
raïs politique au figaro bouge au wali
quadrants voilà en fait ce que
fait c'est d'obtenir un maximum de
correct et les principaux intéressés
de valérie pécresse
républicains oui mais il n'a pas oublié
quand on allait en déplacement et que
commence aussi à parler ça a été le cas
mots
tous les questeurs et est du coup
ce n'est pas une ce n'est pas une
vaciller la droite donc là le rôle
chacun essaye d'être constructif sans
publiquement depuis la réélection des
locale importante ouais tout à fait y
au siège des républicains aujourd'hui à
pour l'instant damien abad qui est donc
dit que le temps des clivages et c'est
et on voit des tweets notamment de tous
monde se demande qui sera le prochain à
cas avec plusieurs maires que j'ai cités
enfin avec vous on va parler de cet
hésitaient auparavant elles rejoindront
il garde un ancrage local important qui
ministre très rapidement nommer les
été exactement ça très bien je verrai
le principal objectif visiblement
sont très implantés
qu'ils jouent bas comme je dis docteur
trahir
c'est à dire le lait l air ne sont ni
beaucoup des ralliements possible à du
affiliés en quelque sorte à la macro
députés un petit peu plus de 100
les militants nous nous parlait nous
finalement décidé de rester au sein de
une une réunion d des sénateurs donc ce
éventualité à écarter entièrement mais
justement c'est ce que c'est ce que je
non il a pris la parole entre les deux
en quelque sorte terminé qu'il fallait
manuels macron donc effectivement voilà
article que vous avez signé aujourd'hui
tout à l'heure qui sont des mères et
ministres seront très rapidement nommer
qui va nous quitter il ya déjà eu un
il ya quelques jours d'aurélien pradié
raconter un petit peu leur état d'esprit
être agressif c'est plutôt en coulisses
raconte que même même eux sont étonnés
les ténors un petit peu du parti qui
ses suites d'un petit peu de débauche
l'air mais qui finalement semble vouloir
actuellement des députés aient l'air à
côté des manuels macro est ce qu'il peut
leur famille politique
travailler ou
n'y a pas d'autres d'autres questions
quand même le secrétaire général des
dans le figaro a retrouvé aujourd'hui
nice est un proche d'edouard philippe et
et les investitures pour justement les
tout se questionner sur pourquoi est ce
fongible dans le maquereau nisme ni dans
actuellement ce serait de décrocher
racontais sur sur les élections locales
qu'on fait c'est que on se retrouve on
tours pour soutenir fermement emmanuel
pour que la nation avance travailler
y avoir des ralliements de l'autre côté
rappelle voilà appel aux dons pour
leur permettra
heures en chef c'est lui qui essaye
et même s'il ne faut jamais dire jamais
l'assemblée depuis les législatives de
des internautes elle est un bon ancrage
ça paraisse ça paraîtrait un petit peu
basculer sous giron macro ni c'est le
il ya eu cet appel il ya cette déception
que je vais vous montrer face à macro
du côté de reconquête par exemple
que nicolas sarkozy n'avait pas soutenu
le lepénisme car il estime qu' il ne met
républicains
qui ont eu lieu finalement depuis les
espèrent les républicains de se
valérie pécresse essayer de nous aider
essaye de rester unis de rester groupés
candidatures aux législatives vont vont
damien abad qui est le président du
2010 est l'objectif
d'aller chercher les personnalités de
et s'attendent un petit peu plus à ce
macron il a appelé à travailler avec lui
avec le président de la république il ya
c'est le cas d'autres mais même d'autres
l'opération survie des républicains un
plus étonnant que ce n'était le cas en
mais pour l'instant il ya une sorte de
aujourd'hui on voit on en voit peu qui
européennes où ça a été le score a été
cas de plusieurs président président de
droite c'est lui qui organise les rendez
règlement a fait un meilleur score que
valérie pécresse pourquoi est-ce qu'il
groupe plr à l'assemblée nationale il a
pas la même hauteur emmanuel macron et
local cependant ils sont affaiblis et ne
être clôturée aussi rapidement donc en
donc voilà à ce jour on en est à 2
qualifier pour le deuxième tour voire
valérie pécresse à la présidentielle on
que ça à ce que ça bouge effectivement
déjà des élus et l'eire qui ont fait le
2010 est effectivement on peut on peut
vous la semaine dernière avec damien
maximum qui a été fixé c'est peut-être
et d'établir une stratégie en vue des
deux pauses médiatique en tout cas de
très compliqué pour eux ils ont en
région aussi donc finalement même s'il
et marine et marine le pen effectivement
voire d'être réélu d'autant que si
cadres de la droite qui qui en offrent
article très intéressant une enquête ce
ne venait pas au meeting
feront pas de pas plus de 8% ccc le
pourrait se laisser tenter par un parent
l'a vu avec guillaume pelletier qui
été courtisé il a été rencontré
dans les prochains jours en europe on
pour autant il reçoit toujours nombre
millions d'euros on en parlait des
abad il ya eu un rendez vous qui a été à
que vous avez signé avec emmanuel
fait on va là on va avoir des
l'avait click id qui avait rejoint sa
de deux d'essayer de dépasser un petit
élections législatives qui arrive très
choix
reste très très fort localement les
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils n'étaient pas là
imagine avec avec la composition du
quelque sorte remporté toutes les
peut-être parlé du rôle de de thierry
l'ex chef de l'état et et on ne sait pas
évidemment son sens qu'on cite leur nom
on à une question d'un internaute qui
par eric zemmour
galiero vous n'hésitez pas tout au long
pronostic de flight on du côté des verts
d'être plutôt constructif avec le
récemment par thierry solère qui est
campagne est ce que c'est possible
différentes réunions qui avait qui ont
c'était quelque chose qui revenait très
gouvernement
peu
tractations sur les jours
aujourd'hui que des d'autres cadres de l
emmanuel macron par sa personnalité son
élections locales les municipales vous
ils savent que ça s'annonce compliqué
d'élus et l'air dans son bureau à paris
l'elysée il ya eu il ya des appels il ya
de sa vie et bien sûr à poser vos
nous parle de valérie pécresse est ce qu
petite précision tout de même
vite puisqu'elles auront lieu en juin
emmanuel macron c'est quelque chose qui
solère qu'on en a parlé un peu tout à
n'hésite pas à faire part de leurs
souvent et également vis-à-vis la dune
semaines qui viennent et après ce sera
questions on va essayer d'y répondre au
ont fait de très bons scores les
conseiller auprès d' emmanuel macron et
on s'attend quand même à un peu plus on
président de la république déjà entre
l'heure tu es chez toi est ce qu'on peut
rue de miromesnil il reste proche de pas
elle a finalement réussi à réunir ces
non on ne sait pas du tout de quoi de
eu lieu justement comment et de ce que
évidemment en coulisses il espère juste
pourrait changer
l'objectif c'est malgré la défaite
reconquête a annoncé aujourd'hui
air rejoignent exe mourou l'extrême
départementales et les régionales malgré
mieux possible comme d'habitude
beaucoup d'appels auprès des députés
entre déjà même avant le premier tour le
cinq millions de dettes alors c'est pas
terminé et la bataille de des
regrets voire de leur agacement voire un
l'a dit on s'attend un peu plus
charisme
vous entendez bien sûr de de l'ambiance
auprès d'autres personnalités donc son
vraiment le sujet du jour mais
effectivement il ya toujours des noms
droite il ya eu effectivement des déjà
etc etc parvient à remporter des
le fait qu'on leur a lancé beaucoup de
quoi sera fait l'avenir et il ne semble
qu'ils ne m'investis ray pas de candidat
malgré la la
première question wali
que ça ne sera pas la bérézina
député guillaume larrivé qu'a pris
des républicains pour le président de la
maintenant on peut en parler
peu plus vis-à-vis de l'ancien président
initiatives pour à pourra commencer très
est pourquoi il a un rôle important
ça va se jouer surtout en fait la
pas être impliqué dans les négociations
le poids de cette défaite la lourdeur de
des ralliements pendant la campagne
effectivement oui bien sûr donc valérie
position en disant que le programme des
est ce que c'est une ambiance de travail
vécu lors de cette présidentielle on
aujourd'hui pour emmanuel macron et
présidentielle
valérie pécresse et les lignes à deux
difficultés une sorte de raz-de-marée
élections à l'échelle nationale c'est
dans plusieurs circonscriptions dont
république la semaine dernière il avait
qui ressortent de personnes qui
que peuvent avoir que peu à voir
bien merci beaucoup ali d'avoir été avec
va dire constructive ou est ce que il ya
contrôler leur finalement thierry solère
de la république donc est le sentiment
il y en a eu finalement peu de poids par
pécresse pour l'instant à l'heure qu'il
stratégie dlr ça va le rester ça va être
cette défaite là d'essayer de rester
pourraient pourraient être appelés a
celles d'eric ciotti
beaucoup plus compliqué à l'échelle
rendez-vous ça a été réveillé d'ailleurs
semaines du premier tour en faisant
parle de 70 80 députés qui pourrait être
nous aujourd'hui je rappelle votre
maintenant c'est tout de même à
actuellement de la macro ni avec avec
donc il était il était parmi les
locale en 2017 il avait remporté
incompatibles avec ceux des républicains
et ça fait jaser quelques quelques
des noms d'oiseaux qui vole comme ça a
par un art urbain berda et
celui de guillaume pelletier
est a réussi à récupérer deux millions
groupés en vue de cette échéance
moins de 2 5% qu'est ce qui s'est passé
article qui va être ici voilà
appelé par le président de la république
pu être le cas par le passé et ben
qui se dégage c'est quand même que
ensuite entre les deux tours où il y en
les élèves dans votre article du jour
relativiser emmanuel macron parvient
françois-xavier bourmaud sur le figaro
effectivement c'est un raz-de-marée
républicains donc il ya encore quelques
législatives les dessous de la guerre
électorale et et de en quelque sorte de
d'euros sur sur l'argent qu'elle a key
par le futur premier ministre
étonnamment n'ont étonnamment ça se
il y en a eu et c'est à une période où
réélu et ce serait pour l'été d'or un
qu'en faisant ce choix là nicolas
entre temps depuis on va dire chez les
feutrée chez les républicains que vous
il ya deux jours ça a énormément fait
républicains
vous parler d'opération survie pour les
ad'autres d'autres élus et l'eire qui
les législatives mais en 2017 il est
années en 2017 il a été parmi les
passe plutôt bien les réunions sont
qui disait
avez écrit avec emmanuel galiero vous
sont un petit peu sorti je pense à jean
parler parce qu'en plus lorsque
les noms qui ressortent le plus sont
limiter des dégâts pour réussir à faire
sarkozy c'est couper d'une partie des
ou eric zemmour était et avait plutôt la
républicains une opération survie alors
là qu'elle a demandé via son via son
républicains alors depuis chez les
l'article 2 de mes confrères ont été a
pouvez retrouver cet article bien
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure damien
je vais me contre vient ici l'opération
on est fongible ni dans le maquereau
françois copé notamment à jean retenir
élire un maximum de députés où ils ont
exaltée également tout neufs s'étaient
résultat somme toute assez correct au vu
évidemment dans le journal du jour qui
républicains il s'est passé beaucoup de
appel aux dons appelé baptisé un petit
d'amis là bas qu'est le président du
survie des républicains c'est vraiment
choses
de nouveau président de la république
le voit sur ces images qui ont été
nice ni dans le pénis mais on n'a pas
le président de la région gros
là on est dans on est dans un temps de
groupe plr à l'assemblée nationale et
été publié les députés aient l'air
est ici et voilà vous n'hésitez pas à
cote
les français souhaitait lui donner une
ça qui est en jeu c'est aussi dans la
écrites qui tournait hier au
peu p creston donc deux millions c'est
de ce qui s'est passé donc voilà il n'y
parlé du zemmour isme voilà
concurrents testent et à d'autres élus
parvenait à percer dans l'opinion a été
survie du parti après ce score oui oui
celui de christelle morancé qu'est la
effectivement l'aveyron faux on se
large majorité pour qu'il puisse
étaient tous en réunion ils ont vu leur
poser vos questions à continuer à suivre
qg des des républicains on voit xavier
réflexion de réunion il ya eu pas mal de
notamment d'aider des mers maire de
peu pour c'est trop peu pour rembourser
a pas d'objectif vraiment chiffrées le
gouverner
portable sonner il y avait justement
oui déjà économiquement ils ont ils
présidente de la région
rappelle de cette phrase de d'eric
là il sort affaibli quand même de deux
l'activité sur figaro live à 16 heures
encore potentiellement qualifiables pour
pas mal de retrouvailles rien que cette
bertrand qui étaient présents de
châteauroux et de saint-etienne et la
tous les frais qu'elle a ok là qu'elle a
damien abad dans la salle et se sont
ciotti qui avait dit que dans 4 2e tour
tout est d'essayer de limiter la casse
n'ont pas pu de se faire rembourser
le deuxième tour là on est un autre
de ses cinq années pouvoir même s'il a
nombreux cadres on l'a dit les
tous regardés un peu mal à l'aise en se
nous aurons l'hommage rendu aux
présidente christelle mancelle après
eric zemmour face à macro il il veut
en revanche je concernant le poste de
leurs frais de campagne donc même s'il y
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé pendant
été largement réélu largement qualifiée
législatives ont lieu dans 47 jours il
invalides à l'acteur michel bouquet nous
d'un président de la région pays de la
moment où eric zemmour a fait pour cent
dépensé surtout qu'elle avait fait un
traiter moi c'est sûrement pour ça que
la présidentielle où effectivement
pour le deuxième tour largement réélu il
avait quand même une santé une santé
certains républicains doivent vous faire
loire qui après le second tour peut
emprunt personnel à hauteur de 2 6
valérie pécresse a fait le pire score de
premier ministre contrairement à 2010
vous donnons rendez vous à ce moment là
ya un objectif en terme de nombre de
également être avec le président la
sort affaibli par les crises qu'il a
remonter ça j'imagine tout à fait
merci à vous en tout cas d'avoir été
sièges et est-ce qu'un hara et qu'elle
république il trésorier des verts daniel
économique
est en fait de la situation est
très nombreux à nous suivre cet
l'histoire de la droite il ya quelque
millions d'euros elle a jusqu'au 15 mai
avant cette élection forcément ça
différente qu'en 2017 françois fillon
on peut parler aussi d'un d'un homme
connu les députés aient l'air les
est il alors l'objectif il a été fixé
après-midi merci wali une nouvelle fois
fasquelle qui a pu être exclue présent
chose qu'il a ce qui va se jouer si on
députés lrm pardon sortent également en
ait fait un très bon score puisqu'il
et à bientôt pour de nouveaux lives sur
complique la donne politiquement
la république pour l'instant ce sont
imagine c'est sogno des ralliements du
qu'on n'a pas en beaucoup entendu
peu plus tard que qu'aujourd'hui dans le
figaro relève
quelque sorte affaiblie ils ont souvent
avait obtenu plus de 20% cette fois ci
pendant cette campagne l'ancien
juste des appels sont des personnes qui
politiquement ils sont affaiblis sur
président nicolas sarkozy qui qui était
côté parce que aujourd'hui est-ce que
été taxé d'incompétence de godillots et
souhaiteraient qui est une collaboration
figaro par le président des républicains
leur droite et sur leur leur centre donc
avec emmanuel macron donc rien n'est
les est ce que tous les élèves vont vous
attendu pour donner son soutien pour
christian jacob lui pense que l'objectif
cetera ils ont fait pas mal de petites
restez dans le bateau malgré ce score
oui il ya une il ya une survie
fait aucun pour l'instant aucun doute
s'afficher avec ilife casillas qui n'a
assez faible de vanité crise
boulettes à l'assemblée nationale qui
pas été le cas on l'a entendu siffler à
effectivement c'est le sujet qui est au
ces élections législatives s'ils
qu'un ténor aucun cadre des dlr à part
un meeting de valérie nicolas sarkozy
sans forcément être connue de tout le
coeur de toutes les préoccupations côté
parviennent à sortir la tête de l'eau
sifflé pendant un meeting c'est quand
monde
l air en ce moment c'est un petit peu ça
même à quelque chose d'assez important
on dégage est quand même une impression
jean-françois copé et qui encore a fait
ça leur permettra de souffler d'autant
un petit peu machine arrière ces
chez les républicains aujourd'hui qu'en
que on l'a vu ils ont été plutôt bons
derniers ces derniers jours en parlant
de
est-il comment les républicains voient
plutôt d'une coalition allemand à
l'improvisation et et tout ça peut peut
voire très bons dans les dernières
l'allemande aucun ténor voilà on a fait
nicolas sarkozy il ya quand même une
élections locales lors des municipales
sorte de 2,2 de point de non retour qui
je pense permettre à d'autres forces
le pas de deux de s'engager auprès du
lors des régionales et départementales
politiques pas forcément les
donc voilà ça leur permettra en plus
républicains d'autres forces politiques
président de la république contrairement
de marquer des points dans ces élections
à ce qui avait été le cas en 2017 oui on
législatives permette de gagner de
l'argent puisque c'est les élections qui
législatives on a justement à
va voir un peu c'est cette infographie
permettent d'apporter des fonds donc
l'internaute alors je vais retrouver ses
qui quiquet dans le journal du jour que
s'ils parviennent à faire élire des
flèches 92 qui nous dit à l'om tient sa
vous pouvez retrouver qui a été fait par
députés à faire des scores convenables
force dans la pérennité de la stature d
service infographie avec 6 avec les
ça leur permettra et de sortir de la
différents noms dont a parlé alors
manuel da cruz voilà c'est ce que ce que
tête de l'eau économiquement et de
nicolas sarkozy on évoquera son cas un
vous disiez pour les municipales je peux
peu plus tard jean françois copé
souffler un peu politiquement pour se
comprendre un vote l air mais pour ce
reconstruire et pour penser à la suite
qui est des initiatives c'est un autre
enjeu voilà on voit on verra donc ce qui
alors je salue flights qui vient dé qui
va se passer dans un peu plus de 40
vient de nous rejoindre chat vous
n'hésitez pas bien sûr à poser vos
jours on l'a dit 47 jours si je reprends
questions on va être encore en live
pendant quelques minutes on parlait
bien de la 47 jours ce sont les
justement de de cette survie il ya quand
initiatives et c'est à ce moment là que
les choses seront intéressantes et qu'on
découvrira ai donc dit d'ici là on
imagine beaucoup de tractations qui
risquent de de ce passé sur dans les
[Musique]